New thing.
This is a new thing.
So because this is a new thing I feel like for some reason,
but it is human nature thing.
I think it is human nature,
but I don't understand what your point is.
Well,
I guess what I'm asking here is,
is is in,
in the way of the,
I just feel like the Russian Bot thing is,
was all of that,
I feel like the Russian bots is,
is a,
is a term for people who don't understand computers in a way,
and they've,
they've just kind of thrown that out there as a political device sometimes
think,
I think that Russia,
China,
Korea,
like every other fucking country that is enabled in a way in which they're so
far ahead technologically was involved in all kinds of fucking fuckery.
And they're still involved in it.
Will still do that during the election.
It was fucking a hundred times.
But,
uh,
you know,
I'm just,
I just,
it's hard for me with,
you know,
back circling around to the Alex Jones thing,
all of this new technology,
all of the people who are awake woke Facebook on Facebook.
They know you're in HR,
you're woke on Facebook,
so awake,
you know,
it's like a,
I felt bad for fucking childish Gambino that he had a song that had stay woke
and it,
because immediately that song that that was what an amazing song and it was a,
it was uh,
that that term became dumb immediately.
But I,
but I just feel like,
um,
all of this that's happening,
all of this talk,
all of the him getting banned,
all this stuff,
it's all this kind of like effect of the world instead of being out in the
world.
Everyone has,
has,
has gone to this point where it's,
you know,
these groups,
these really rich cribs,
Google and Facebook and Twitter and all this and everyone has,
has gone to this central point and other lynching people,
whether or not you agree with Alex Jones,
whether or not you like him,
whether or not I think he's being launched there.
So I get,
I get that there's all these people that are doing all these different nefarious
things and this has been going on forever and now they're using new systems to
do that.
They using the internet and all these open pipes and these connections that they
can make trick is that the public is there.
They've gotten them to go to this a one arena.
That is my problem with it.
Is it like as much of a nerd and a technology person?
I am.
I like,
I hate that people have instead of really,
I mean I'm sure they have their own lives,
but like the fact that we have become so centralized to these small groups of
Internet companies like social media and things and then now look,
it's on both sides,
man.
I mean Alex Jones is getting lynched.
Harvey Weinstein,
whatever.
I know he's,
he's a very different things,
but every,
everyone is a very,
very,
very different than not defending him.
But I understand how you made this behavior,
but do you understand the connection is the connection connections.
People are just attack the findings.
The minute it look,
those people could have suits against Harvey Weinstein,
Stein Steen,
and we can know about it.
Of course we knew about it because the Wall Street Journal or whoever,
or New York Times who were in that thing,
but then New Yorker.
Yeah,
it was the New Yorker.
Yeah.
But like,
I guess my point is,
is,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I'm sure this is an unpopular opinion,
but I just feel like that the centralization of society into social media is
resulting in a lot of things that are very ugly.
And I think that the Russian Bot thing,
the Chinese hackers thing,
the Alex Jones issue,
the me too movement,
all that stuff,
which I,
I'm,
I'm behind all of the people that,
that were hurt.
I'm not on behind the sandy hooks,
people on behind the people who had the bad experiences in Hollywood,
all that I'm buying.
What are you proposing?
I'm just saying that I think that,
that it's unhealthy.
I think that social media thing has become too centralized.
There needs to be decentralized,
uh,
sort of centralized because there's only a of groups like Facebook and Twitter.
They are Instagram.
I mean,
it's 100% centralized.
it's owned by a group,
several groups.
It's several,
uh,
you know,
everyone's kind of going to Mcdonald's to have these conversations as opposed to
it being something that is a little more healthy.
I just find,
I just think that that people,
I think Alex Jones should have always been able to be crazy in his world.
And he was always nice to me.
And you,
like you said,
he's your friend.
Like,
you know what the problem with Alex's,
he needs someone sitting right next to him.
Someone like me,
someone who when he talks and he said something crazy,
go wait a minute.
Wait,
how do you know that?
And he goes,
well,
we have the documents will show me the documents.
Well,
the documents don't say that.
you know,
the problem is gel or they are definitely trying to influence.
And he'd go,
yeah,
they probably are.
But if you leave them alone,
if you leave them alone and just let them rant.
By the way,
he's doing six hours,
eight hours of radio a fucking day.
And he's definitely likes to drink.
So he's doing six hours of radio a day.
At least three of them are drunk.
And he's fucking fill in time and screaming and no one could say anything to
him.
And he's the fucking man over there.
That's also part of the problem.
He's got a bunch of these other people that are around them all the time and are
conspiracy theories as well.
But there are 28 and you know,
and then you know,
they're hanging out with Alex Jones and it goes on these rants and no one
interrupts them.
It's a broad argument with all of it because I agree.
But he was always,
he was always transmitting.
He was always like,
Hey,
show me where the Satanists are going to worship.
It took to sacrifice children.
That's fine.
But I get,
I think what happened is now the idea is that he's influencing people
politically.
Like the whole,
you know,
the whole uh,
Podesta pizza gate,
that all that stuff was scared the shit out of people.
And that guy showed up at that pizza place and fire off around and you know,
and then they want to arrest them and they really thought there was a dungeon in
the basement where again,
kids centralizing in social media is the cause for a lot of these reactions.
Is that centralizing and social media or is that people exciting people to and
take action against something that may or may not even be real if you are you
allowed to yell out fire in a crowded theater,
right?
This is ultimately the problem,
It's not whether or not he believes in Bohemian Grove,
which is real.
And he proved it on video back when they had VHS tapes and I watched it.
I mean,
I've known Alex since 99 or 98 I think maybe I've known him for a long ass time
and this is a very big difference between then and what's happening now is as
far as the reach and influence,
and I think people are sort of panicking about reach and influence and what it
means and how to mitigate it,
how to change people,
how to stop people from going into pizza places and shooting them up because
they think that something that they heard online is true.
There's a lot of stuff that people hear online.
There is just not true,
you know,
the lizards underground or the fucking earth flat.
There's a lot of stuff that's just nonsense.
So it's,
it's hard to separate.
Here's what I think.
I think we are going through an adolescent stage as a,
as a being,
as an evolving being.
And I think our bodies and our minds and our consciousness are becoming
synchronized with technology and along the way,
like right now we are in this chaotic screaming,
sweating,
crying,
pissing,
shitting,
state of chaos.
And we're looking to figure out how to stop the bleeding.
We're looking to shove thumbs into dykes,
dykes meaning like dams and we're looking to try to figure out a way to stop the
bleeding.
We're trying to put patches and bandaids on things.
We're trying to manage the chaos.
We're trying to figure out what,
and this is a stage that we're going through because this,
hold on a second.
This is a new thing.
This is a new thing for human beings.
The ability to communicate widespread over millions and millions of people
instantaneously is a new thing.
So people have say that never had say before they have influenced it never had
influenced before.
They have their ability to contribute and they might not have thought these
things through and these things catch fire and they run through dry forest like
a goddamn tornado of,
of,
of flames that you see on CNN when men to see no fire up in northern California.
This is what happens with ideas because there's no way to contain them and they
don't know what's right or what's wrong.
I think that what we're going through from the period of 1994 the period of 2018
is like a crazy fire in the middle of a hurricane.
It's like everything is nuts and no one knows how to stop it and no one knows
what to do.
And what do we do?
We get together and shelters and we fucking give people water and we tried to
stop the fire and take away everyone's lighters.
And that's what we're doing right now.
We're trying to take away lighters.
We're trying to stop people who start fires.
And this is what's happening with Alex and it's,
it's not that Alex is a bad guy,
is that he has,
he's by himself.
Okay.
It's irresponsible to say that you know for sure a fact that these parents from
sandy hook or crisis actors and their kids never died.
It's irresponsible.
And he didn't think it was irresponsible when he was doing it because he's
probably caught up in what he does and he's caught up in the wave of ad libbing
just like you and I are ad libbing.
We didn't even talk about what the fuck we're going to talk about.
Right.
We just turned on and where we had a couple of drinks.
You're what you're saying there is very right.
And I don't mean to cut you off.
It's okay,
but,
but what you're saying there is very smart because to me,
uh,
you know,
it is,
you're right.
He,
he has always been doing this and it just point in time his reach has grown
right now there's a wind behind them.
He used to be in Seattle,
it was raining every day and he had a little patch of dry newspaper,
like that shit on fire and everybody go,
hi.
Alex is crazy.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I think,
I think what I'm trying to articulate and I'm not doing as well as I wanted to,
but I think what my problem is is the synchronization of consciousness is what
I'm not into.
I think that,
I think,
you know,
just like you have a Rut of people who believe that,
uh,
you know,
they now believe that the sandy hook thing is fake and they're calling the
families because of this conversation.
This is where that lawsuit is really coming from because the other people,
but then you also have another side of it.
And it could be,
as you know,
back in the day when they said that Paul Mccartney was dead,
but they got harassed,
but it was on such a small level because there was no way to just email Paul
Mccartney and,
or email and say,
you're not the real public McCartney.
You're fucking dead.
Not just that.
There was no way to exchange these ideas amongst
real time on Facebook all day long,
which is the centralization that creates these rivers and in these ruts that
people who don't know what to do and they fall into one rut or another and they
kind of become this,
this,
this kind of streamline thing.
So I think the way you just described it as is very,
um,
articulate this new thing.
Matt is a new thing.
When we are in a really exciting time.
But why?
Why I say that?
Because they used to say that about the printing press.
They used to worry about that with the written word.
They used to worry about that with everything.
The distribution of information is not,
it's not whether or not it's healthy.
It's just a part of what the this being does with this being does is constantly
search for innovation and novelty.
That's what,
that's what the human being does.
But like the,
I guess I guess yes,
but it was looking at your phone over there,
man.
You got to fucking iPhone.
Don't you think you'd go to the people make an iPhone and go,
hey bro,
we're good.
Yeah.
Yes.
Is it,
this is stop.
You can stop.
It's not,
we're not good.
These mother fuckers are ready to come out with the iPhone 11 then like the guy,
you're not going to stop.
The [inaudible] has been at the web was invented hyperlinks and the idea was
that if someone want to be too hard to,
this is just,
Oh,
I'm in,
I'm in.
So like the guy invented the web got stolen.
His name and I should know is Gore mother fucker.
However.
Right.
That's funny.
He lies.
So this cat,
this cat,
eh,
all he wanted to do was make it basically where like medical documents where you
would,
where you would say like,
you know,
this guy had a brain transplant and then brain transplant will be underlined and
you clicked on that and it would take you to a link that explain brain
transplants and that would be worldwide.
So the Internet is decentralized and the web is decentralized to some degree.
Okay.
Now Google coming in with search engines,
like that's focusing points.
What scares me is those people being like Facebook being the avenue in whichever
it be talks like I,
I would just scare you.
Is that weed I just handed you holy Shit.
I took two hits and I'm not even here anymore.
I'm an Auntie.
I am very high.
That's a blunt.
That's legit or took two hits.
I liked the little,
I'll fuck around here in California Sun.
But you know what I mean?
Like I just have a problem with the centralization of the companies owning the
avenues in which get taught.
I right.
I'm right.
I'm right with you on that.
I think we need more youtube.
I think we need more venues for people to distribute,
distribute information.
But I also think we need more love,
more compassion.
There's so much hate and anger towards each other.
Let's keep,
I,
I feel like I'm going to get arc nailed here on this because I'm not,
I am not.
Well,
it's part of the nervousness about doing a live show,
right?
Yeah.
I'm,
while you were talking about,
and I would say,
um,
well I mean I'm very nervous right now.
I haven't fucking drink but,
but I would say I'm very nervous.
I would say that,
um,
oh,
this is one of those ones where they,
that's,
that's tobacco,
tobacco and some shit that was growing on Mars.
You know,
Armstrong grew weed,
man.
See I again,
again,
it was just like there was a point when you're trying to make sense right now.
This is part of the problem,
right?
I know.
This is why I wanted us to get out of it.
And we're getting,
we're getting super serious about topics that are very,
that mean a lot to people and we don't really know enough about it.
I just,
I just feel like,
I just wish that there weren't,
like,
again,
I just,
I feel like there's reps that have people have to fall in to communicate and
[inaudible].
Those are ruts that are owned by these companies that,
that are very fucking rich and very well.
Here's the thing too.
These companies didn't see this comment like I'm libertarian.
I'm not either way.
And just in the sense I'm not really that,
I don't even fucking know what that is.
All I know is I don't believe in trusting anybody who,
who,
who says,
Hey,
I'll take care of you.
Come this way.
Just don't worry about a thing.
And they're the ones making all the money.
And it's like,
that's how the Internet has become.
It used to be a wild west of information.
Emails are fucking information that is,
that's me communicating with you and no one else seeing it.
That's beautiful.
And I think the idea of Twitter and Facebook and all that,
it's fantastic when it first started,
but at this point in time it's gotten so big.
If it doesn't break up into something where people figure out that they are in
control of the Internet,
not these other people.
That's what bothers me.
What bothers you is it someone comes along and says the people aren't in
control.
The Internet,
so it's not like a free market.
So in the free is the funds aren't come up.
It was a free market.
It's a free market.
A guy like Alex Jones,
you'd say this guy is preposterous.
I'm not listening to him anymore.
When it's not a free market is when youtube collapse.
I Dunno if they collaborate,
if they just all grows.
I don't know if they all agree,
but they just all decide everyone's gonna take 'em off.
Facebook's gonna suspend him for 30 days.
Twitter's going to suspend it for a period of time.
Youtube is going to remove him.
All these people are going to take Vimeo jumped on ship and they pulled them off
too.
So this,
this becomes an issue.
Like,
what is it that causes you to get removed?
What is it and should we be really clear on that?
Or is this just a whim?
Because this is a really important thing.
If we really are fucking with free speech,
we have to be very careful on what we decide.
Is is a valid reason to pull people off of our airways?
Because if you have stuff on your airways that's far more vial and you let that
stay up because it doesn't have the same reach,
like what is your criteria?
It doesn't have the same influence.
It doesn't have the same political ties to it.
Like what is the reason why you're pulling one thing off and not another thing?
Is it because of the popularity issue?
Have you searched your trillions of fucking hours of footage for offensive
speech,
content ideas,
uh,
disinformation,
what have you,
what have you really done to mitigate this issue?
Or are you acting on this because it's a social hot spot issue right now,
which it most certainly is and most certainly should be.
I really think that Alex needs a guy right next to him.
He really like,
I understand this.
And I did a show together and Howard Stern,
man,
no,
not the same comparison because Howard's,
but listen man,
let's do them every day.
But sometimes I want to be like,
dude,
are you kidding me?
But that's also part of his charm.
Part of his charm.
She creates descent in arguments and you want to get mad and you want to either
he's opinionated.
Well,
but how it's turns very responsible.
He's a different guy.
It's not,
it's not the same thing.
I'm not trying to compare Alex to him.
I'm just saying that sometimes I feel the same way about it,
about him,
and not to feel that way about us right now.
This is quit cutting fucking Giorgio Moroder tribute records and do a country
record.
You know,
and I do a country record right now and they're like,
oh,
it's Kinda corny.
No.
Uh,
now I got a record coming,
by the way.
I'm sure you do,
Dude.
I'm a.